data by any other name would still be as
sweet
but
how dost thou process and transform data
aka data is very powerful but how do you
process and transform it
join me as i show you with apache beam
[Music]
in this video we'll walk through a
demonstration of apache beam if you
haven't seen the last video i recommend
checking it out since we talk about some
of the key concepts that make up a
pipeline in beam there's a link in the
description
in this example we'll walk through using
beam to count the words from
shakespeare's king lear and we'll show
what it looks like to use google cloud
dataflow as a runner
this is a great starting example of a
batch data job since we're working with
a file which is bounded as opposed to
streaming data processing which is
typically unbounded because there's no
fixed start or end let's take a look at
what our batch data pipeline does
here's what the pipeline looks like the
first thing we'll do is read from a text
file that contains the entire copy of
king lear after that we'll use
transforms to split each line into
individual words count the instances of
each word and output the results
each p transform takes a p collection as
input and sends one out as output so we
can chain together the transforms
so first things first we can check out
the input file this is just a short
snippet but the entire book is included
in the text file we'll be using
of course there's lots of words in this
book so let's get started counting them
in this example we're using python so
the first step is to install the apache
beam files we need after that we can run
the word count example and specify the
input and output files
since we're not specifying a runner the
default is to use the direct runner
which runs the pipeline right on your
machine
if you're just getting started or
looking to debug the direct runner is
likely how you'll want to run your
pipelines after all beam is designed so
you can run the same pipeline code on
different runners
your local environment might be fine for
king lear but what if your batch data
job was counting all of the words for an
entire library's worth of books in that
case we can just provide a few more
options to the code and use google cloud
data flow as the runner instead
the input file comes from a publicly
accessible cloud storage file while the
output will be a cloud storage bucket
that i created earlier
we're also specifying to use the data
flow runner and some other details like
which google cloud project this runs on
once we run this command the job will be
created in dataflow and start processing
let's take a closer look at the code
the core part of the code happens here
after the pipeline has been set up with
these options that we provided
this first part of the pipeline reads
the text from the input file and creates
a p collection of each line from the
file
from here we use 3 transform from the
line's p collection the first transform
to split the line into separate words
one transform to turn each word into a
single count of one and another
transform to group and sum all of the
words and counts the pipe operator for
beam in python is short for applying a
transformation to a collection so with
this short block of code we're able to
chain the p transforms together by using
the output p collection of the previous
transform as the input
part do is a transformation that takes
each element from the input p collection
and performs a function on it in this
case we have a custom regex that simply
looks for groups of non-white space
characters and splits each line of text
into words
the final transform formats the text
using a custom function and finally
outputs it to the bucket this is a
fairly straightforward pipeline so these
few transforms are all we need
while this is running let's take a look
at data flow in the cloud console you
can see the status of the job in each
step of the pipeline the name for each
transform step comes from the code
you can also click on each step to see
more details over time the interface
will update and pretty soon the pipeline
will be complete
beam is designed to run pipelines with
parallel processing so if you're working
on a large batch or streaming data job
the pipeline still looks the same
thankfully google cloud and dataflow
will handle all the infrastructure
details for us so with just that short
bit of code we've been able to get a
count of all the words now if we take a
look at the output file
we can see the count of all the words in
king lear
however you might notice that there are
two separate counts for the word king
that's because we didn't take
capitalization to account when grouping
the easiest way to fix that would be to
add another p transform after we split
the sentence up into words we could
simply lowercase all the words and then
pass that p collection over to the group
and sum transformation
apache beam is a powerful tool to help
you process data and the word count
example we just went over is a simple
way to get started there's some links in
the documentation with more information
including an interactive tutorial you
can take right in the google cloud
console
thanks for watching
[Music]
you